SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: All
right, well, good afternoon,
everybody.
I'm Scott Giambastiani.
I'm with the food
team here at Google.
It's great to have
everyone-- sold out, awesome.
Raise of hands.
Who here is at their first
cooking class at Kitchen Sync?
Raise of hands.
I'm just curious.
2, 3, 4, 5, 6?
6 and maybe 7?
So welcome to Kitchen Sync.
It is my pleasure to introduce
Laura in a couple of seconds.
I want to give a quick
background on-- hopefully,
you know why you're here.
Raise of hands, who's
been to the Berkeley Bowl?
Woohoo!
Awesome place.
Very, very exciting.
So I want to give a quick
background on Laura,
and then she's going to dive in
and prepare some of the recipes
from the cookbook, which I
had the pleasure of reviewing
in full detail.
I was talking to her earlier.
I get a lot of cookbooks
that come past me, obviously,
being on the food team.
And this is one of the
most exciting books
that I've seen in a long time,
because it talks about so
many unique ingredients
that you see often
on shelves and markets--
farmers markets, et cetera.
And she's done
such an amazing job
in making such a very
approachable book,
to look at these
ingredients in a way that
are so simple to
execute but so tasty
and really highlight the
deliciousness of them.
So congratulations.
So a quick intro, and
then we'll get let
her get into the good stuff.
So it's my pleasure to
introduce Laura McLively, who
has authored the "Berkeley Bowl
Cookbook," which celebrates
the unfamiliar yet extraordinary
produce of California's most
iconic market--
the Berkeley Bowl.
The cookbook offers
recipes on a variety
of fruits and
vegetables, some of which
she's brought with her to kind
of pass around and play with,
that are really largely
overlooked in popular cuisine.
I think as culinarians,
as home chefs and chefs,
we really get focused
on ingredients
that we're so familiar with.
And what's really
unique about this book
is you're able to take a
dive into some ingredients
that maybe you haven't
seen for a while,
or execute them in a way
that maybe you haven't
seen before in the past.
So Laura is a registered
dietitian, an avid home cook,
creator of the popular
blog, "My Berkeley Bowl."
And she's created recipes from
really the unfamiliar aspects
of the exotic fruits and
vegetables within the market.
The market has easily
over 1,000 vegetables
and produce items out there.
And she's taken those
hand-selected ones
that she feels are the
most unique and overlooked.
Some of the ingredients--
or some of the recipes
that you'll actually
see in the book,
that I thought were
super exciting,
were things like the
kiwano melon cooler,
the falafel waffles with
Armenian cucumber slaw,
or the burdock root pizza.
She will be sampling three
different items today
that she'll speak
to, but I wanted
to please have everyone
give her a warm applause
so that she can
dive into cooking.
So please welcome Laura.
[APPLAUSE]
LAURA MCLIVELY:
Thank you so much.
I'm really exited to be here.
I was telling the Google
team earlier that this is
my first time here at Google.
And I've been trying to make
it here for quite awhile.
And I'm excited to finally
have an excuse to be here.
So thank you so much.
And thanks for that
really nice introduction.
We are going to get
right started cooking,
because I'm sure moments
will come up where I can talk
a little bit more about my
inspiration behind the book,
but you're here to
see a cooking demo,
so we're just going
to get started.
The first dish that we're
going to make is a beverage.
It's called shiso limeade.
And there's various
kinds of shiso.
So actually, this from the
Google garden right here.
This is red shiso.
And you also grow
the green shiso.
And the one that we're using
today is called Chinese shiso.
So you have to be
kind of careful
when you're going to
make this recipe that you
are sure you are identifying
the right kind of shiso.
So Chinese shiso
looks like this.
It's a leaf that's commonly
used in Japanese cuisine.
And it's-- you're going to
look for kind of a heart-shaped
leaf.
It's two tones-- the green on
top, and purple on the bottom.
So you might have seen shiso
before when you order sushi.
It sometimes comes on the plate
with the wasabi on top of it.
But a lot of people don't know
that you can actually eat it.
So today I'm going show
you one of my favorite ways
to prepare shiso, which
is in this limeade.
So I actually came across
this recipe by mistake.
I knew I wanted to serve
shiso as a beverage
because it kind of has this
refreshing, lemony, herbal,
minty scent, but a really
nice earthy undertone.
And so I thought, well, that
would make a really great tea.
So I boiled my water,
and I went ahead
and added the leaves to it.
So we're just going to do that.
It's really simple.
It's this hot water.
And I let it steep for
about 15 to 30 minutes
so that that shiso flavor
really infuses the water.
And so this is what it looks
like after 15, 30 minutes.
And so I took the leaves out.
Usually you just strain them,
but for the sake of the demo,
we're just going
to use some tongs.
And you can see that
the water is clear.
It comes out like a clear tea.
And I tried it, and I thought,
well, that's really delicious,
but I can't really put
that in a cookbook,
like "add leaves to water"
and, call that a cookbook.
So I was like, what am
I going to do to it?
So I thought maybe I'll chill it
and I'll add some lime juice so
that it's kind of like a
refreshing non-alcoholic
beverage.
And this was one of those really
rare moments in the kitchen--
or actually it's not so rare.
This is one of those special
moments in the kitchen, when
you're playing around with
foods and you discover
something exciting and magical.
So I'll show you what happened.
So I added the lime juice.
And it turned this bright
pink color, like bubblegum.
So I had no idea this would
happen, and I was just like,
oh, my god, this has
to go in the cookbook.
So we just sweeten it with
a little agave nectar.
And that's it.
And so you're just going
to serve this on ice.
And it's so nice to
serve this at a barbecue
or party at your house as a
nice, non-alcoholic option
because people expect
it to be pink lemonade,
and then you can kind of
see on their faces they're
surprised by this
flavor in the background
that they don't
really recognize.
And so that's shiso.
So we'll just pour
ourselves a little glass.
And it's nice to
garnish it with--
I shouldn't have put
all the leaves in there.
It's nice to garnish it
with some leaves and maybe
a slice of lime.
So you can see, it just
has such a beautiful color.
And kids really like it too.
I just had a Memorial Day
barbecue, and I served this.
And the kids had, like, no
idea that it was this weirdo
herb that they never tried.
So there you go--
shiso limeade.
So as you can see,
something like shiso
that maybe you'd pass
at the grocery store,
or you've seen it at the
farmer's market, you're like,
well, I don't know that it is,
I don't know what to do with it.
What you find when you start
to bring these things home
is that they're not as
intimidating as they look.
And so the thing
I really learned
in working with these
fruits and vegetables
is that what's maybe
new to me and kind
of foreign and intimidating
is as normal to someone else
as apples and
potatoes are for me.
And we should find out why.
There's probably a
really good reason
why it's normal to maybe someone
in another part of the country
or another part of the world.
So shiso is one of those foods.
And so let me just move
this out of the way.
Thank you.
Thanks.
I brought some other
fruits and ve--
we're going to prepare
a couple other dishes,
but I brought some things
that I found at Berkeley Bowl
last night, that
I thought we could
play a little identification
game together.
So here's some of them.
So has anyone seen this before?
OK, great.
What is this called?
AUDIENCE: Rambutan.
LAURA MCLIVELY: All right.
So does anybody know why
it's called rambutan?
What "rambut" means?
Take a guess.
AUDIENCE: Hairs.
LAURA MCLIVELY: Hairs, yeah.
Rambut means "hair"
in Malaysian.
So that's why this
is called that.
In the book, the recipe for
this is you just cut around
this and take off the top.
And there's a lychee-like
fruit in the middle.
And you dip these
in white chocolate
and dust them with
a little clove.
It's a really simple
recipe to enjoy something
that looks really crazy.
Does anyone know what this is?
AUDIENCE: Cacao?
LAURA MCLIVELY: Good guess.
Not cacao.
AUDIENCE: Banana flower.
LAURA MCLIVELY: Banana
flower, that's right.
So these are little baby
bananas, not yet born.
So these, you can take
off these outer petals
and save them as a serving dish.
And then there's a core
in it that's sort of
like an artichoke heart.
And so you can slice that
up, and in this recipe
it's stir fried
with glass noodles,
and then you serve in the petal.
So we'll do a couple
more of these later,
but we'll probably
want to move on.
OK, so I should mention too
that the cookbook is organized--
the chapters are organized
by the type of plant
it is, or the part of the plant.
So for instance, the shiso
is out of the Leaves chapter.
And then next, we're going to
be doing sea beans and soba out
of the Succulents chapter.
And the reason we did that is
because when you're shopping
at a store like Berkeley
Bowl, or when you're
shopping at your farmer's market
or at the local ethnic grocery,
usually it's an
ingredient-centric shopping
experience.
You're not there saying,
like, I'm going to make this.
You go, and you wait
to see what you find,
and then you develop
a meal around it.
And so I really wanted
the book to be organized
in that same way, where you're
focused on the plant itself,
and then you built
your meal from that.
So the sea beans are out
of Spores and Succulents.
And actually, I don't
see my sea beans.
So maybe they're still chilling.
So while the sea beans
are on their way,
I'll tell you a
little bit about them.
So sea beans are a
aquatic succulent.
They grow in salt-water
marshes on the coastline.
So one of the cool
things about them
is that they're
native to this area.
Thank you.
You can actually
go out and forage
for sea beans on our coastline.
And you can also grow these if
you have a pretty salty soil.
But you can forage
for them, or you
can go to stores like Berkeley
Bowl or farmer's markets.
And I know that they
actually serve them
in the Google kitchens
too, so a lot of you
have probably had these.
But I love to just walk
around Berkeley Bowl
and kind of watch
shoppers examine things,
like, oh my god, what
do you do with that?
And it's kind of
a community where
if you see someone
grabbing something
that you don't
recognize, there's
permission to ask,
like, OK, well,
what are you going
to do with that?
And, what does it taste like?
So that's how I learned a
lot with just hanging out
at the store and
kind of observing
what other people were doing.
But sea beans are the one
thing that, when I grab them,
people are constantly asking
me what I do with them.
And the reason I
love these is you
really don't have to
do anything to them.
Because they are
a succulent, they
have that, like, nice
crispiness like you would
expect from biting into, like--
think of these as kind of
like miniature aloe veras.
So it's filled with this
really nice, refreshing liquid
that bursts with salt water
when you crunch into it.
So I find it super addicting
to just snack on these
by themselves.
You can also throw
them onto a salad.
You can stir-fry them.
You don't want to cook them
too long because then they
lose that crunch that
makes them so special.
So in this recipe, we're doing
a sea bean and soba salad.
And the reason it's my
favorite way to eat these
is because soba noodles
are really silky and soft,
and so it's really nice to
have them mixed with this kind
of similar width item that has a
nice, different contrast to it.
So to get started, we have
water boiling over here.
So we're just going to
cook our soba noodles.
And soba are actually--
they're Japanese
buckwheat noodles.
And if you have celiac disease,
or you're gluten-intolerant,
buckwheat doesn't have
gluten, so they're
a nice gluten-free alternative.
You just have to be sure that
you check the ingredient label,
because a lot of soba noodles
that you find at grocery stores
are actually mixed with wheat.
I'm not sure about the
ones in this kitchen,
but if you're cooking
these at home,
just buy a package that
says "100% buckwheat."
So with soba noodles, they
can get mushy very fast,
and so it's very
important-- we're just
going to put these in the pot.
It's very important to cook
them about a minute or two less
than it says on the package.
Because I find if
you go the whole way,
they always cook a little
longer after you take them out,
even if you run them
under cold water.
And they can get
mushy very fast.
So typically that's maybe
for five to seven minutes you
want to cook theses.
Fortunately, we don't
have to wait that long.
We have some already cooked.
So what I do at home
is I drain these.
I run them under cold water.
And that helps stop the
cooking, but also it
washes off some of
that starch that-- you
know when you cook
noodles and they sit,
and they're in this, like, glob?
So we don't want that.
So you wash it off.
And then I immediately
add the sesame oil.
So the reason I do that is
because, one, it prevents them
from sticking
together, and two, it--
maybe this is in my head, but I
think it kind of creates, like,
a protective coating
around the noodle
so that it doesn't continue
to soak up moisture and get
soggier and soggier over time.
So maybe that's-- like I
said, maybe I invented that,
but I think it works.
So you're just going to
kind of mix those up.
And then I like this
salad pretty chilled,
so I put this in the
fridge for about an hour
or overnight if I'm
making this ahead of time.
And then I pull it
out right when I'm
ready to assemble the salad.
So this is really easy dish.
All we're going to do--
our sea beans are done.
We don't have to do
anything to them.
We're just going to add some
brightness and some crunch
to the salad through
some green onion.
So for green onions--
oh, they've already
removed the tops.
So I don't really have
much to show you here.
We're just going
to put these down.
I can tell you a little
bit about knives.
So use whatever knives
you're comfortable with.
My favorite is this really
banged up nakiri knife.
This is a knife specifically
designed for vegetables,
and that's because it's--
rather than a
chef's knife that's
curved and is meant to be
used in a rocking motion,
the nakiri knife is flat-edged.
And so it's really just
an up-and-down knife.
So you can kind of do that--
across the cutting board
and chop really fast.
And you don't end up getting
those strings of vegetables
that are still attached
to each other, right?
Like when you cut celery, and
then you take your knife away
and you find they're
all still in a row.
So I like this knife
because that doesn't happen.
There are prettier
versions of this
that aren't chipped and rusted,
but this is the one that I use.
So we're just going to
run our knife through.
And for the green
onion we use the white
and the light-green parts.
Has anyone ever cut themselves
on a filming of a Google food
talk?
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Yeah, we
have good editing, though.
LAURA MCLIVELY: That would
be a chef's darkest moments,
if you, like, cut off your
finger in one of these things.
So we're going to chops those.
And then we are going
to use some chili.
And you can use, again, whatever
peppers or chillies you like.
I'm going to go
ahead and turn these
off because, let's be honest,
this was just for the demo.
We're not going to use those.
You can use whatever
chili or pepper you like.
I like Fresno chilies because
they have the same heat
level, similar to a jalapeno.
But they're red.
So typically, when
you're cooking
with a lot of
vegetables, there's
a whole lot of
green in there, so I
like to seek out chilies
to add some color.
So the easiest way
to slice a chili
is to just slice the
chili off of the seed.
But then you end up with strips.
So if you want julienne
it, that's fine.
For this salad, we're
going to slice it
in rounds just because it
looks a little prettier.
So what you can do is you just
slice up until about halfway
when the seeds start.
And then, once you see seeds,
you can take a little melon
baller or a small spoon, and--
this is my little compost
pile--
and just scoop out the seeds.
And that way, you get rounds but
without the white pit and the--
or the white membranes
and the seeds.
The seeds are where
all the heat is,
so if you want some
of that extra heat,
you can keep a couple
and throw them in there.
But I usually cut them out
so that it doesn't upset
people who aren't spice lovers.
So then it's pretty
fragile because you've
removed the seeds.
So you want to be careful if
you are using a chef's knife,
that you don't just crush it
and open up the nice disc.
So you just want to be
a little more careful
and maybe slice so
that they stay intact.
So there you go.
You have your cut chili.
So we're going to
actually add a cup.
And they've already
pre-sliced these for me.
And then they
pre-sliced my onions.
Just [INAUDIBLE] things.
And then they pre-sliced
my Thai chili.
So I love-- sorry,
not Thai chili.
Thai basil.
I love all kinds of basil.
And in my garden, sometimes
this one looks funky,
and I use the regular basil.
It doesn't really matter.
But if you're trying
to keep this kind
of a Southeast Asian dish, you
could go with the Thai basil.
And then while this
is kind of sitting
over there doing nothing, we
want to toast our sesame seeds.
So I usually use
black sesame seeds.
How do I turn this on?
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
LAURA MCLIVELY: Hold it down.
SPEAKER: And now go ahead and--
LAURA MCLIVELY: Go up, OK.
So I like using the black
sesame seeds because they just
provide such a nice contrast.
You can see them
better on dishes.
Did I do that right?
Oh, I'm using the wrong burner.
SPEAKER: That's
actually a timer.
LAURA MCLIVELY: That's what
was beeping over there.
I was like, why is this
pan not getting hot?
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]?
LAURA MCLIVELY: Yes, thank you.
Black sesame seeds
just look so pretty.
And again, I think it's
one of those things that
are underutilized in kitchens.
Oftentime, you see sesame
seeds on breads or pastries
and on salads, and it's
always the golden ones.
And so once again, just even
if you just go to the store
and pick out a different
spice or something
different from the
bulk bins, I think
you end up realizing
how versatile it is
and how much fun you'd have.
One of the things I'd love
to do with black sesame seeds
is to make tahini.
So we've all seen
tahini, and it's
kind of peanut-butter looking.
My husband is definitely
allergic to peanut butter,
so I tend to keep things
away from the house that
even remotely look like it
because he's just like, ugh,
what is that?
So usually I buy
black sesame seeds,
and I make that into a tahini.
And it's really
glossy and beautiful.
And in fact, it's in one of
the recipes for treviso spring
rolls.
So kind of like a
Vietnamese-style fresh spring
roll.
And you dip it in the
black tahini afterwards.
Which, I see treviso out
there in your kitchen,
so I'm glad to see some of
the items in this cookbook
out there.
So to test the sesame
seeds, we're just
going to add them to the pan.
And this takes about a
minute or two for them
to start to smell fragrant.
You don't want them
to burn, so just
kind of shake your pan
every once in a while,
and make sure that
they're moving around.
And when they smell [INAUDIBLE],,
take them off and let
them cool so that they don't
continue to cook in the pan.
Because there's nothing worse
than burned seeds and nuts,
right?
So give those a little shake.
And then we're just going
to make our dressing.
So for our dressing, we
have some minced ginger.
I'm being a messy cook.
Let me move these
out of the way.
We're going to do some fresh,
minced ginger, some soy sauce.
And again, if you're keeping
this recipe gluten-free
by buying 100%
buckwheat noodles,
you could also
use tamari instead
because that's the gluten-free
alternative to soy sauce.
So lime juice and our honey.
So typically in
Southeast Asian cooking,
you're aiming for a nice balance
between salt, acid, and sweet.
Or really in all
cooking, really.
But particularly in
Southeast Asian cooking,
you want a little bit
of sweetness and lots
of acid and some
salt. And so that's
why we're adding the honey,
is for that sweetness.
And last but not least,
our rice vinegar.
And actually, I hear my
little sesame seeds popping.
Yep.
So you just want to kind
of stick your nose in it,
and when it smells
done, it's done.
OK.
So we're just going
to whisk this up.
And dump it on.
And last but not least, we're
going to add our sea beans.
So, like I said,
you don't really
have to do anything to these.
They're best
chilled, because they
can get kind of, like, limp
if they're out too long.
And really, you can just
put them in as they are,
but if you have some
that are really long--
these are actually pretty tiny.
But some of these are long.
And so let's say
you're having someone
over, like your special friend,
and you're cooking for them.
You don't want mouthfuls
of succulent tentacles
falling out of your mouth.
So you can put them
on your cutting board,
and maybe run a knife
through it once.
You don't want to
chop them up a lot,
but just kind of do one
in half so that there
are more bite-sized pieces.
So we'll just add this.
And this bowl is going to
be really hard to toss in.
Maybe I should have made
that my compost bowl.
Let's just pretend this
chili is not in here.
Thank you.
Perfect.
Let's see how many bowls we
can dirty in the kitchen.
So we'll just give
this a quick toss.
And then I want to put
it in something pretty,
and they gave me a
really nice [INAUDIBLE]
that has a good
color contrast to it.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
Would you typically want
to serve this
immediately, or do you
find that it does
a little better
with a little bit of
time in the refrigerator?
LAURA MCLIVELY: I like to serve
it immediately so that the soba
noodles don't get too soggy,
and also the sea beans
are really [INAUDIBLE]
chill, so just kind
of toss it and serve it.
But, that being said, I
always make extra and take it
for lunch in a Tupperware
the next day, and it's great.
It just kind of lose--
like the Thai basil will
be a little more bruised,
and it just won't
look quite as nice.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
So spoiler alert.
Before we started the filming,
chef was having lunch,
and this is what
she was eating, so I
know it's one of her favorites.
LAURA MCLIVELY: It is.
Actually, so there's about 100--
just sprinkling the toasted
sesame seeds on top.
There's about 100 unique
fruits and vegetables
featured in this book.
I don't like to say exotic,
because exotic to me
is normal to someone else.
So there's 100 unique fruits
and vegetables in this book
that I took home to play
with for the first time
and develop these recipes.
And of all of them,
I think sea beans
are my favorite new friend,
or at least in my top 10.
So I hope that you
leave here today--
I guess my ultimate hope is
that you leave here today
excited to pick up
that thing that you've
seen at the farmer's market
or at that ethic grocery
store on the corner,
and kind of marveled
at but not felt
comfortable taking home--
I hope you bring it home.
And just think, there's
probably a new best friend
that you haven't discovered yet.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
It looks great.
LAURA MCLIVELY: The
sea beans and soba.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
These will be served
a little later after the demo.
I want to highlight--
just I was looking
over the ingredients.
This salad is super exciting
not just visually, but obviously
when you taste it.
And being at Google, we
serve salads at almost all
of our cafes.
And so one of the
things that I look
at when we are
looking for really
crave-able,
plant-forward salads,
is how do you get someone
to want to come back
for that second bite.
And if you think about this,
visually it's stunning,
but it also has a lot
of elements in there
that are going to kind of
tease that palate, right?
You've got all
that umami in there
from the soy sauce, the chili.
So there's a lot
of great elements
that I think you're
going to extremely enjoy.
LAURA MCLIVELY: Thank you.
Yeah, this could be one
that you guys serve up
and have as a standing
salad in your kitchen.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Love it.
LAURA MCLIVELY:
Feel free to steal.
OK.
So our last recipe we're
going to demonstrate
is lemongrass coconut ice cream.
So I realize that most of you
have had lemongrass by now.
It's not so much an
obscure ingredient.
But I still think
that I've met--
a lot of my friends and a lot
of fellow cooks I know still
haven't worked with it.
It's like we have it
in Southeast Asian
cooking when we go to a Thai
restaurant, but a lot of people
haven't actually
prepared it at home.
So once again, it's
like making these things
kind of familiar parts
of our everyday cooking
can really add some variety and
fun and a sense of discovery
in the kitchen.
At least that's
what it did for me.
So coconut-based ice cream
is my favorite, because--
I do eat regular ice cream
too, but the cool thing
about coconut ice
cream is you can--
something's beeping
again, the timer-- you
can have it a moment's notice.
Rarely do I keep
large quantities
of cream just sitting
in my refrigerator,
but I always have a can or two
of coconut milk in my cabinet.
And so you can have ice
cream instantaneously.
All you need is an
ice-cream maker.
So usually the
coconut-based ice cream,
you just want to add
something to flavor it.
And I love lemongrass because
it has that really nice zingy,
citrus-y taste.
Like it actually kind
of zings in your mouth.
And even a hint of pepperiness,
sort of like ginger.
And so it's a nice way to cut
the richness of pure coconut
milk that has a
high fat content.
You do want to use real regular
coconut milk, not light,
so that you get a
nice creamy ice cream.
So all we're going to do
is prepare lemongrass.
I hope you're seeing how
easy these recipes are.
It is very approachable.
So things that might
look intimidating
are actually quite easy
once you get used to them.
So what we're going to do is
just slice off our root tip.
And then I like to bruise
them sort of like you would
garlic to release the layers.
And also it helps break
down the cell walls
and get that lemongrass
oil infusing and releasing
from the layer.
So you could just take--
I don't want to use my
really fragile nakiri knife--
you can take a chef's knife
and just kind of whack it
with your hand along the stalk.
And then we're just
going to slice it.
It doesn't have be precise.
This is just to create
some surface area
for the coconut milk.
This is basically a two or
three-ingredient ice cream,
depending on whether or
not you want to add ginger.
So it's kind of as
simple as making vanilla.
So you can use as much
of it as you want.
I kind of stop once I get up to
the part where it branches off.
And then we're going
to repeat that.
If there's some layers
that look kind of--
you know how onion
or celery or fennel
have some of those outer,
brownish layers that
look like they've
touched everything?
You can remove an
outer layer like that,
and then do your bruising.
This one looks fine.
If you have delicate hands,
you can use, like, a--
my mom has a wooden mortar
and pestle on her counter.
And she always just
took the actual mortar
and banged it on her
garlic or whatever.
And here's our last stalk.
I used three because I
like it quite lemony.
And also, this is growing
in the Google garden.
So you guys are growing
a lot of these things.
I have this growing at home, but
mine is kind of spindly still.
It's not big enough.
OK.
So making this ice cream
is as simple as putting
this in a pot.
And you're going to
add your coconut milk.
They have these huge
industrial-sized cans
of coconut milk in this kitchen,
so that's why it's pre-poured.
But at home, this would
be about two cans.
So we've got our coconut
milk and our sugar.
And like I said, if you'd
like, you can add some ginger.
I just add a couple
coins, three or four.
And you just heat it.
So you put this on your stove,
if I can work this burner.
This one, on.
And the goal is just
to get it to the point
where it's simmering,
because since this
is sort of an infusion,
you're really just wanting
to treat it like a tea.
So get the coconut
milk to simmer,
and then you can turn
it off and let it sit.
So what I do is I,
once it's simmering,
I let it sit for about
15 minutes in the pot
that I'm simmering
it in so that it's
infusing at its maximum heat.
And then you take this mixture,
and you want to chill it.
Because when you're
making ice cream,
it's really important
that the solution
that you're putting
in the ice-cream maker
is as cold as possible.
Because if it takes
too long to freeze,
you end up getting ice crystals.
So I usually will kind of
make this up the night before
and keep it in my fridge.
And then when we're
sitting down for dinner,
I throw this in my
ice-cream maker.
It takes about 15 to
20 minutes to freeze,
and it's done by the time
we finish our dinner.
I feel there's nothing--
it's a really nice touch
to serve homemade ice cream
when you're having people over.
And they think it's
like this big deal,
but it's really super simple.
And so it's a nice way
to serve people something
that seems special but that
doesn't take a lot of time.
So I don't think we'll we
for this to actually simmer,
but let's just pretend it's
simmered, we've chilled it.
And if you want to chill
it fast, not in your fridge
overnight, you could
just set up a ice bath.
So put a bowl in a
larger bowl of ice
and kind of let it
sit there and stir it.
That will take maybe 30
minutes to get it to the point
where it's really chilled.
And then-- I don't think I
have an ice-cream maker here,
but they've used it.
But you would turn on
your ice-cream maker.
And in the interest of not
dirtying extra equipment,
I just hold a strainer,
a fine-mesh strainer,
over the ice-cream maker,
and I dump it directly in.
And it keeps out the solids.
So we basically want to leave
the lemongrass and ginger
in there as long as possible so
that it's infusing to the max.
So that's it for
the cooking part,
but hopefully that
leaves some time
to see if you guys
know your stuff
and can identify
some of these things.
And then we can
talk a little bit
about the inspiration behind
the book and Berkeley Bowl
and things like that.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Awesome.
Round of applause.
LAURA MCLIVELY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: So for
those of you on the video,
you can't smell the
amazing essences in here,
but you will be tasting
the food shortly.
So we will be
opening it up to Q&A,
which we can start at any time.
I know that Laura has
her personal cookbook
up there that we're
reminding you to take home.
LAURA MCLIVELY: Oh
yeah, thank you.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: As well
as some other ingredients
that you may want to
discuss a little bit.
And then we'll go
into some questions.
So if you have things
that are on your mind,
if there are specifics
within the book you'd
like to learn more
about, we have probably
about 25 minutes before we
go into the book signing.
So think about those questions.
And I will kick it off with
just some general questions
that I had, which is--
we get this a lot as chefs--
how did you get into cooking?
LAURA MCLIVELY: So
I always grew up
in a household where people
were cooking all the time.
So my mom, she was from Spain.
And my dad's family
was from Greece.
So we just always had good
plant-based food at home.
We weren't raised vegetarian,
but we rarely ate meat.
It was maybe for, like,
Thanksgiving or something.
And so I was around a lot
of produce and vegetables.
And then I also lived
in Spain for a while.
And so I think just
seeing how food
is such a way to bring people
together, and also a way to--
a statement that you can
make about how you're
caring for the
world and how you're
caring for your own body, that
I just really got into it.
So I did study
nutritional science.
I'm a registered dietitian
by day at the Native American
Health Center in
Oakland and also
in the Mission District
in San Francisco.
So I deal with food in
kind of a clinical context,
but I really enjoy
just kind of the art
of playing with food at home.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Very cool.
I know I asked this
question earlier,
but just going back
to the Berkeley
Bowl-- who has not been to
the Berkeley Bowl before?
And I'm not singling anyone out.
You can't see on camera anyway.
But there's some cool
fun facts about the Bowl.
So it used to be
a bowling alley.
It's owned by a husband and
wife, and now their son.
They've owned it
for several decades.
There's two locations, correct?
LAURA MCLIVELY: Mm-hmm.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: And you
said there was over, what,
1,000-plus different
ingredients in there?
LAURA MCLIVELY: Yes.
So for those who haven't been,
the reason this store can
inspire a whole cookbook--
I don't work for
them, by the way.
A lot of people think I do.
I'm just a shopper who
was inspired by the store.
And it's because
it's hard to find
another place that has so many
produce items under one roof.
This book is usable
even if you don't
live next to Berkeley
Bowl because it's
kind of like a fun
treasure map to go find
these things at a
certain farmer's market,
and then maybe you go find
nopales at the Hispanic market.
And then you can find burdock
root at the Asian market.
But you'd have to go to a
lot of different places.
And that's fun in its own right.
But the cool thing
about Berkeley Bowl
is all those things
are under one roof.
And that's because Glenn
Yasuda, the original owner,
his family were farmers.
And Diane, his wife, her family
owned another produce shop
in Berkeley.
And they really had this
dream of opening a produce
store in front of the
house where they lived,
sort of like things
are in Japan.
And so they bought
this bowling alley
that was in front
of their house,
and they turned it
into a produce shop.
So originally, it
was just produce.
And he has always had
this commitment to,
if I can find it,
I will provide it.
And knowing that he
has this store in one
of the most culturally
diverse areas in the country,
with over 112 languages
spoken in the Bay Area,
he kind of knew, well, if I
can find this niche item, if I
can find taro
leaf, there will be
someone that is
excited to see taro
leaf at their local market.
And he was right.
He kept finding
these niche items
and providing more
and more and more.
And more and more
people came, knowing
that they could
find the foods that
maybe were from their cultural
background, all in one spot.
By the way, this is simmering,
so we're going to turn it off.
So when I first set
foot in Berkeley Bowl,
I saw things like this.
And granted, this
is a room with a lot
of people from maybe
different backgrounds
as well, so some of these
things might be normal to you.
Like Scott was saying
his wife is Fijian.
And so she grew up eating
Indian bitter melon.
But maybe she didn't grow
up eating salad savoy.
And so it's kind of cool because
you can go to this store,
and you're always
going to find something
that you don't recognize.
But when I walked in, I saw
these things, like this--
this one's kind of a small one,
but these can get up to, like,
3 or 4 feet, this root.
And I'm picking it up,
like, what I do with this?
Like, oh, my god,
this is so cool!
And so again, I kind of would
ask people that were also
picking it up, what is this?
What does it taste like?
And then ultimately
kind of got the courage
to bring these home
and experiment.
So usually I'd bring
it home, and I'd
try it a couple
of different ways.
Like, I'd grate it, I'd cook
it, I'd braise it, I'd roast it.
And then I'd see what
way I liked the best.
And I tried to do that
before looking it up,
because it's really easy to kind
of pigeon hole an ingredient
into a certain context, like,
oh, this has to be prepared--
like this is typically--
well, it's used a lot of
different ways in Japan,
but oftentimes it's grated and
simmered in a sweet solution,
and it's used as a
topping on things.
So it's like, well, I
don't want to repeat that,
so I try to play with these
things before looking them up
and come up with my own ways
and my own family dishes
to incorporate them into.
So there's a lot of Spanish
and Greek dishes in this book
because that was my background.
And then also a
lot of dishes that
were inspired by travels,
and just living in Berkeley
and eating out.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: So before
the food comes to you--
and they're plating it up now-
are there additional questions?
Anyone have anything they
want to ask at this point?
Because I will keep
talking, if not.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you have
a go-to blog or site
or anything that tells you
kind of how to pick produce?
Because it's cool to see a
bunch of different options,
but I have no idea how
to pick the right one.
LAURA MCLIVELY: Yeah, that's
a really great question.
So she asked if I
have a go-to resource
for learning how to select
and work with produce, right?
Well, first of all, I
forgot to mention that,
so I'm glad you brought that up.
To take the mystery away,
I-- for every item that's
featured in the book,
there's a sidebar,
and it has how to select
it, how to store it,
when it's available,
and substitutions.
Because not only-- like, if
you were living in an area
where you just could
not find salad savoy,
I want to make sure that you
can make the dish nonetheless.
But also because you might fall
in love with a recipe, and then
the item only has
a two-week season.
So for instance, there's
a fiddlehead tempura
in here with sriracha
creme fraiche that I love.
But fiddleheads are
only around for a couple
of weeks in the spring.
So you can make that--
I recommend using
asparagus or green beans.
So I always list substitutions.
But in regards to your
question about resources,
one of the sites I
found really helpful
is called "Specialty Produce."
They have a really great website
that has everything on there.
You can type it in,
and it will tell
you its ethnographic
information, how to select,
how to store.
And then also what's cool is
they say recent sightings.
So, like, "recent salad
savoy sightings," and it
lists restaurants where
these things have recently
been featured on the menus.
So I really love that
because then I think, oh, I
want to go see what they did
with Indian bitter melon,
or I want to see
what they did with--
what are some-- oh,
like lotus root.
That's one of the more
beautiful vegetables
that you can find that looks
like lace when you cut it open.
So yeah, I think
specialty produce.
And then the other site that
's really helpful is "Food 52."
Has anyone--- yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
So that's a really great
website that really goes
into depth on each ingredient.
And I think they
have recipes as well
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: So when you
started to write this cookbook,
is it what you
thought it would be as
far as the investment of time?
Were there any surprises
along the way on the journey?
Anything you would
do differently?
LAURA MCLIVELY: I should
say, so a lot of the recipes
ended up coming from my blog,
and that was just for fun.
You guys all work
at Google, so you'll
think this is pathetic,
but, like, I didn't even
know that you could tag blog
posts to make them searchable.
I wasn't doing any of that.
I just was doing it for fun.
And so at that time, I
wasn't thinking of it
as a time investment,
because it was just for me.
But then once I signed
the cookbook contract,
I was surprised, actually.
It's like coming
up with 100 recipes
maybe doesn't sound
crazy, but I was doing it
while still working full
time as a clinical dietitian.
And so that meant I spent pretty
much every evening after work
just standing in the
aisles of Berkeley Bowl.
Because you never know what
you're going to find there.
And so it was really hard to
develop some of these recipes
because I'd find sour plums,
for instance, and go, cool!
I haven't seen these
in the store yet!
And I'd take them home,
I'd come up with a recipe,
and then I'd go back
to get them to test it
and they'd be gone already,
because these things have,
like, a one or two-week season.
So that made it challenging
and kind of delayed
some of these recipes
coming to fruition,
because I had to wait
for the next season
when these things
were back available.
And actually, a
little anecdote is
that testing was
also a challenge
because we wanted to make
sure every recipe in the book
was tested at least three times.
And so something to has a
really short season, again,
by the time I developed a recipe
and the editor approved it,
the item was gone.
And so I actually had some of my
friends living in New Zealand,
they became recipe testers.
So it was great because
they had opposite seasons.
So they had, like, a
six-month lag where I'd say,
OK, this one's ready, let
the New Zealand folks test it
because they'll be able
to find it in six months.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Awesome.
Yes, in the back?
AUDIENCE: Is there a Berkeley
Bowl equivalent in New Zealand?
LAURA MCLIVELY: Is there
a Berkeley Bowl equivalent
in New Zealand?
It's called, like, large
sprawls of land where people
can grow their own veggies.
So no, I don't think
there's an actual--
I don't think there's a Berkeley
Bowl equivalent anywhere.
There are some really great
produce markets all around,
including LA.
But Berkeley Bowl
really is unique.
So for those who
haven't been, please
make that a field trip there.
It's really just hard to
find all of these things
under one roof.
And not only to find,
for instance, shiso,
but to find five different
varieties of shiso.
So you have options.
They have 15 different
kinds of pineapple.
It's like, who needs to choose
between 15 different kinds
of pineapple?
But if you're really
particular about the size
and the level of acidity and
the country it comes from,
if you want to shop with kind
of a social-justice conscience,
then you can make your
selection and choose,
I want a pineapple from this
country over that country.
So no, I don't think
they have that.
But my testers there, they
were really into farming,
and so they grew a
lot of the stuff.
They tested the cardoons
because cardoons also
have a pretty short season.
And so they even had those
growing in their garden,
and they could test those.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Laura,
what recipe in the book
are you most proud of?
I know that we talked
earlier, and there
are some really
interesting ingredients
that people might like to
hear more about and kind of
how you got inspired to
come up with the recipes.
LAURA MCLIVELY: Yeah,
I think the recipe
I'm most proud of is--
the example you used about your
wife-- the Indian bitter melon.
So can raise your hand if you've
tried Indian bitter melon?
OK, now keep your
hand up if you've
liked Indian bitter melon.
OK so we have, like,
eight people here.
That's phenomenal.
Usually, when I ask
that question, like,
all the hands go down.
So some people grew
up eating this.
And it's really, really
good for you, I should say.
It has really strong
anti-carcinogens
and antioxidants in it.
So I have patients
that will just
blend this and kind
of plug their nose
and drink it like a smoothie.
But I wanted to find a
way to make it palatable.
And the problem is
that I think when
I heard that it was
bitter melon, I was like,
OK, I like bitter.
I like coffee.
Yeah, I can do this.
And I bit into it, and
it's not like coffee.
To me, it really tastes
like ground-up aspirin,
like really medicinal.
And so it kind of made
my mouth go, like [GAG]..
And so I tried to make
a curry and cover it up
with a whole bunch of spices.
That didn't work, so
then I was like, well,
maybe I need coconut milk to
make it like a Thai cream.
That will cover it up even more.
And that made it worse.
It's almost like the fat
drew out the bitterness.
Then it was like Aspirin soup.
And it was just a disaster.
And so I persisted,
though, because I really
wanted this ingredient
in the cookbook.
Because it's, first
of all, really
cool-looking, and also
very good for you.
So then I just kind of changed
my course, my plan of attack.
And I thought, I really should
try and go with the bitterness
rather than trying
to cover it up.
And so I thought
of things that I
like that have that
same medicinal quality,
and I thought of tonic.
Because I love gin tonics.
And tonic water has that
quinine, that kind of, like,
bitterness to it, that if
you were to just have it
on its own, it might not taste
that great, but in a tonic,
it's wonderful.
So I experimented with
recipes, and I ultimately
came up with a homemade
tonic that you can
make using Indian bitter melon.
And you do it with grapefruit
and lemon and juniper berries.
And it makes this
distilled tonic
that you can keep
in your fridge.
And you can just pour
it with some club soda
and ice for a
non-alcoholic drink,
or it's really good
as a gin tonic.
And actually, one
of the sous chefs
here came to one of my
talks at Omnivore Bookstore,
and we served it there.
So one person has had that,
at least, but I hope--
whoever wants to take these
two home and try that recipe,
you're welcome to.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: We have
time for one last question
in the back.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So while I'm excited
to try unique ingredients
like this, what are
your tips on introducing
your recipes to picky eaters,
like kids or husbands?
LAURA MCLIVELY: Do
you have picky kids?
AUDIENCE: No.
LAURA MCLIVELY:
So she asked what
are my tips on introducing
these things to picky eaters.
Oh, did I just turn off my mic?
We're good, OK.
So I have a six-month
old, so I, unfortunately,
don't have quite a
lot of experience
in feeding my kid
with these things,
or feeding my kid these
things, because she just
started to eat.
So we're on the sweet
potato level right now.
But I think food is
all about the attitude
that you serve it with.
And again, even adults
can have a hard time
looking at something
new and seeing it
in the context of
their own kitchen.
So I think it's just about
going with the attitude of fun
and discovery.
And I actually, at one
of my books signings,
a French mom came up to me with
her, like, 10-year-old son,
and she's like, my son never
wanted to eat vegetables,
but we got your book, and he's
treating like his project.
So he had all the
pages earmarked,
and he'd written notes
in the columns of, like,
"buy agave" and things that he
wanted to remind himself to do.
And she said they cooked their
way through eight recipes
already, and that he was really
excited because it was kind
of like cool things, right?
It's not like the typical
spinach and broccoli
that his mom was giving him.
So I think, like,
what kid wouldn't
be excited about peeling this?
If you involve your kids
in these sort of things,
it can make it more fun.
But yeah, I think just going
with that sense of discovery
can make a big difference
for a picky eater.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
How is the food?
AUDIENCE: It's so good.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: I
can't wait to dive in,
so I'm going to
selfishly ask everyone
to give a huge round of
applause so I can eat some food.
LAURA MCLIVELY:
Thanks for coming.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
Thank you very much.
LAURA MCLIVELY: Thank you.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Great job.